he's described the fbi search of his
florida estate as an un-american
unwarranted and unnecessary raid and
breaking but donald trump says he's
encouraging the release of the warrant
even though it was drawn up by what he
describes as radical left democrats and
possible future political opponents
the request to unseal the warrant is a
rare move by the u.s justice department
and according to the attorney general
that's because trump himself disclosed
the search i personally approved the
decision to seek a search warrant in
this matter
second the department does not take such
a decision lightly
where possible it is standard practice
to seek less intrusive means as an
alternative to a search
and to narrowly scope any search that is
undertaken
if the motion is granted the warrant
will be made public and could reveal
what investigators were looking for
it's reportedly connected to allegations
the former president removed sensitive
files from the white house search
warrants usually remain classified
during a pending investigation
the election is rigged public interest
is mounting along with fears of violent
responses from some of trump's far-right
supporters claiming that things may have
been planted by the fbi an extraordinary
allegation no matter what the
circumstances are with donald trump no
matter what he has done
he is always able to present himself as
the victim
on thursday an armed man tried to breach
an fbi field office in cincinnati he was
shot and killed in a standoff with the
police
posts on trump's social media platform
from an account bearing the suspect's
name mentioned the attempt to storm the
fbi office and encouraged others to
prepare for war
the man is also believed to have been
part of the january 6th attack on the
capital mohammadval al-jazeera